Colossus est un personnage connu dans l'
univers Marvel et ce qui le rend
difficile à gérer dans le monde CG, c'est
qu'il est brillant parce qu'il est entièrement fabriqué à
partir d'une surface métallique, nous
devons également faire ces réflexions
dans l'environnement chaque fois que nous terminons le
tournage.  notre acteur de capture de mouvement Colossus,
nous finissons par entrer et nous tournons
des plaques propres qui nous permettent simplement d'avoir
toutes les informations dont nous avons besoin
lorsque Colossus se déplace, puis nous
tirons également des boules grises réfléchissantes et
des boules argentées réfléchissantes qui permettent à l'
artiste des effets visuels  pour comprendre d'
où viennent toutes les sources d'éclairage
, puis en plus de cela, nous
filmons les yeux HDR avec un appareil photo fixe
et nous allons donc entrer et ils installeront
un appareil photo fixe et ils filmeront toutes ces
passes panoramiques à  les expositions multiples
et celles-ci doivent avoir des
informations de réflexion de sorte que lorsque l'
artiste des effets visuels place le type de
corps chromé sur Colossus, il utilise ces
informations HDRI avec leur réf  lection
passe pour obtenir une sorte de toute cette
cartographie de l'environnement autour de lui
parce qu'il est essentiellement un miroir géant
qui se déplace et qui permet à
Jonathan et à notre sorte d'équipe VFX de
faire cette transition transparente vers cette
personne métallique qui se déplace comme un humain
et agit  comme un humain mais a cette
forme très surnaturelle